welcome to this video this is Simon
Williams again and he's going with his
Dutch stuff no he doesn't
so I don't have don't get a Dutch at
least that's clear
okay so we get some kind of Kings Indian
maybe yes he's going to a king's in yeah
and I didn't even know that he has this
in his repertoire it makes sense it's
horse it's an aggressive opening let's
see what he's doing
not bt7 is kind of a little bit unusual
not not a bad move but it's not very
very common that's a strange move let's
let's think about this for a moment
Bishop them where is he going with this
bishop
okay I'm going back h3 now threatens
some win over piece I has to go back or
three seven one of the two so I can go
h3 Knight f6 don't need to but it's
interesting let's do that then Bishop e3
essentially I've got the same position
as before just have the move h3 extra
and now he's trying for f5 again okay
yeah well I have I have ideas I have h4
Angie come on let's go h4 now that there
is absolutely no pressure only four I
can do h4 h5 as well you know g5 does
not H - oh wow
what is he doing he allows the Bishop c4
just like that okay so what is that what
is the point here
check check there on check on d3 so I
can't play Queen you're three if I like
let's do that not sure about the me but
is this interesting just cover that for
the moment it wasn't even very dangerous
in the first place but but still okay
should have gone to eat - well I should
have gone to eat you that would have
been better
hmm I think better I didn't I didn't
really understand this position well
enough okay can i play g4 here takes
Queen takes e4 hangs that's that's bad
news and he gets in g4 maybe okay well I
didn't exploit his opening play
correctly I didn't play that one okay so
let's see I can go f3 it's kind of mmm I
don't know
f3 g3 night everyone I don't know if
that's a good idea
h5 pawn might fall okay let's get there
not any huge rush here to do anything
let's see
hmm sometimes g3 also is an idea but f3
I know let's do this let's go back here
getting this back into the game
yeah h5 is hanging definitely is ok
let's do it like that and switch to the
Queen side yeah I didn't really I didn't
really play that anyone any good
really really bad
Jeff he just finished the heroin's this
h5 pawn that's a sad truth
hmm since it doesn't want to take it
just yet maybe has some different idea I
know he know he took it okay and I have
to somehow get my pieces more active
don't don't know how exactly that sets a
big issue him I can could put a knight
on h3 maybe I should do that actually
it's not so easy to break down
I can't yes maybe you can sacrifice on
the forum hmm I think I think I think I
think no didn't do it so let's step back
there cover
mm yeah I won so I should have taken
this thing should have chicken this
would have been much better it would be
much better if I would have would have
taken taking the the night time morning
in this case it wasn't even that easy to
win I mean it is a win of course for him
but it wouldn't would have been still
somewhat somewhat tricky at least check
hmm country queen unfortunately come on
what the heck
check queen a-sixes unfortunately always
trading Queens okay it's a very slight
hope yeah yeah okay that wasn't
unnecessary loss quite resigns that was
badly played I really played it badly
yeah from here that that's terrible what
I do that's really terrible and what
definitely should have a good position
here I get the light squared Bishop
straight it does this should be really
okay hmm I wonder though
okay let's that doesn't that isn't right
so maybe Queen e2 is still plays Knight
f6 yeah I don't get it blockaded maybe
maybe this isn't so bad maybe that isn't
so bad well maybe I should have played
an aged 6 cm that said that sets in fact
interesting maybe I should have played
deckings yeah I should have played that
one Vigo was back and let's let's see
it's very interesting
can I go g4 even he might round up he
might round up the pawn I could have
played g4 though
hmm maybe that's what I should have done
Jim that's a bit bit better for white
the position but not much I wanted to
really refute this stuff and maybe
that's not really possible
he gets the knight to f6 it's very
important for control over g4 he
controls g4 this those LightSquared
weaknesses are not not really really
critical
yeah that that was yeah well after f3
I'm basically giving up on the pawn I
don't know yeah I mean I made one clear
mistake later I mean okay I'm I'm worse
that's it's clear with the pawn but I
made one mistake later just I mean he
could have played better as well
but what I'm what I'm doing wrong here
here here after Knight g5 I have to take
here B takes Knight takes bishop shakes
and then the block I don't think I can
do that position that's a complete
fortress that's a fortress a for not b5
and over for for a for positional wrong
yeah I absolutely I forgot to take or
I'm when I when he removed it let's say
I realized that this wasn't problem yeah
not be something that sets a big issue
damn he gets the Knight to g5 and that's
it with the with the blockade yeah so
age six a maybe age six is the issue
then I didn't didn't play that move it's
tricky with his King here I mean I
couldn't even just play Queen c2 and nan
castles I should have done that that
that's a very inconvenient pawn to have
near the king I also have ideas to to
open up the position sometimes yeah like
Knight the way and g3 something opening
up the king and
age six porn is really irritating I'm
not sure about the computer the computer
gives a wider plus one I'm not not sure
how good it really is but that's
interesting interesting to try ok well
thanks for watching